right i open the committee of conference
on uh house bill 1099
with
uh amendments and
this as it's presented to us
has four parts to it the original bill
and then three add-ons and what i'd like
to do is discuss briefly each one of
those four sections
get a sense of where we are and then
come back and
decide what we want to do
so the first section you'll see is
relative to medical freedom in
immunizations
and clarifies that no person shall be
required to receive a covet 19
vaccination in order to receive benefits
or services from dhhs
and open for comments from anyone
i don't think
the health and human services committee
even
amended this section
but i'm checking that right now okay
and
anyone else while he's checking
all right mata or mr chair thank you um
okay i'm i'm just i'm looking at the
matrix and i think this is going to be
very helpful once i figure out how to
read it
uh
at the bottom of the page that was also
wednesday go ahead yeah the bottom of
the page one communicable disease and
then it runs onto the second page what
what is that supposed to represent it
was that to represent an amendment that
both the house and the senate had
specifically to 1099 or to another bill
i believe it shows that we were in
agreement on that but
um
is that relative to 1099 or a different
bill i think to 1099 but the word i got
from the
republican leader of the house is this
is moot
because um
it's already been handled in other
legislation that's passed so the first
thing is really
not relevant or not needed
and in other words if we kill it we're
not really killing anything is the word
he gave me
wait a minute
hunt we're looking at the first part you
can be waiting ahead of course
did you find what you were looking for
you made a slight change
the
i was showing you the introduced thing
as opposed to the house pass
and so they're identical
and the senate that the provisions
and medical freedom is exactly the same
that's what i see
people's thoughts on
section one here i i
i could see myself concurring on that i
i
my memory is not great but i think that
this may have gone through division
three and i had a chance to work with
representative cushman to to make some
adjustments that the senate bought off
on and
i i i'm fine with this
once again republican leaders said that
it was not needed because it is
now been handled elsewhere which
to me never means kill it it just means
we we really mean it now because we said
it twice
but that's just me and i'm wordy
anyone else
just senator yeah just a question so was
it handled in another bill
this session or it's already an existing
law
well it hasn't been signed
seeing nothing further
section
two
is about the special supplemental
nutrition program for work farmers
market and so on
representative edwards we were talking
about this beforehand
uh yes yes mr chair i
um
this did come to division three and i
did have an opportunity to talk to the
advocate
or lobbyist for this
and what
we concluded from that conversation i
think i may have talked to you also
senator whitley
was that the 300 000 couldn't be spent
anyways because
uh the money can only be paid out july 1
to september 1 something like that and
there was just no way in this initial
year that they were going to be able to
get the program up and running
and so what i
had been willing to do in division three
but i i guess i dropped the ball which
is on a workload issue i don't know what
it was but was uh to go ahead and seed
the program with like 10 000 or 15 000
that would let um the department go
forward with things like rfp rfi
and and also
in order to execute the program they
have to have vouchers
and the vouchers get handed out and so
they need to print the vouchers so i
wanted to give them enough money to get
sort of the administrative
overhead taken care of but it didn't
need anywhere near 300
000. please
so i had a different understanding and i
don't know if someone from the
department
is here
is the lisa from the department here
henry
here john's here on the back
so my understanding when we came up with
this number we developed it so that
the coupon that people brought to the
farmers market was 30
because
it's expensive to go to the farmer's
market and so you need to make the
coupon enough money so people will go
so i think we had some discussions
representative about the administrative
side of it and whether
they needed that much on the
administrative side but we do need
enough for a 30 coupon
okay so
so i actually think i have a pretty good
memory on this which is rare
but what what i what i'm awfully sure of
is that they couldn't stand up the
program this year from july 1 to
september 1. so they didn't need 30
because they couldn't get it into the
marketplace so
but and and then if they were to start
this program with the
vouchers july 1 of next year
that's the next fiscal year that's the
next budget
and so
so i was willing to seed it
and i i it was either 10 000 or 15 000
because they just didn't need they
couldn't spend the rest of it and july 1
is the new fiscal year anyways so
but but mr williams has a perfect memory
i'm sure
up for the record john williams
legislative director for health and
human services and i'm actually
fortunate uh the department doesn't have
anyone here today to respond to your
questions and to um
and to reflect uh your memory of this
particular bill but i do want to say to
um to the bill that department was
supportive and supports the underlying
bill and we do have representatives who
could answer your questions here from
the audience so uh chairman pearson if
they could be allowed to come up they
can address your questions a team to the
front
and just to clarify they're they're not
with the department but they're very
knowledgeable they're still a team
good morning i'm tiffany dodier from new
hampshire hunger solutions and i've had
some conversations with uh rep edwards
and and senator whitley and um also lisa
sirois at the department so last
conversation that we had um
with uh
lisa cervois was that
the seed money would be much appreciated
and that i can't speak to exactly if
they would not be able to spend the
money this year but the the
the likelihood of being able to get the
program up and running this year would
be a challenge for the department so not
speaking for the department this is
again third person conversation so um i
think that that they would be completely
happy with with seed money as well
such as the seed money as representative
edwards may have mentioned
um i can't speak to the exact amount i
know yeah i know i think that her and i
had spoken more around the 30 000 but i
think that
but it would be quite difficult to get
the whole program up and running in six
weeks
correct or actually it'll be less than
six weeks because this has to pass house
senate and be signed okay
hi good morning for the record my name
is rebecca boykovsky i'm the kids count
policy director in futures and i've been
working with tiffany and
our state partners on this and i just
want to concur with that understanding
around the challenges of implementing
but how important the seed money really
would be for this program
senator yeah so
um thank you for that that's helpful um
the other piece to it was that
the
my understanding is that the department
had already made the request to the
federal government or sort of let the
federal government know so they're ready
to go as my understanding
um ready to go
they have the approval from the federal
they have the yes they have the approval
from the federal government the dates
are fuzzy to me about i think i think
that they can implement it in the next
um the next summer and still use the
same plan and that's that would be fine
i think the plan is approved for either
this year or next year and i think
they've already had some communication
about that
follow-up follow-up thank you so
you may have heard
in the news that there's a shortage of
infant formula
and the vast majority of people who are
having trouble accessing the formula are
wic
recipients is that your understanding
yes
um and so i i certainly understand the
need to be fiscally responsible i just
want to make sure if there is any chance
we can get this going that we have give
them the opportunity
so maybe some somewhere between 300
thousand is the right number i just it's
also three hundred thousand dollars is
budget dust particularly when we're
talking about you know hungry babies and
hungry children and so you know i'm
wondering if we can come up if you had
any thoughts about a middle ground on
the number
i'd be really hesitant to speak on on
behalf of the department i'm not sure if
you
have any representative edwards
so just to clarify this this
we all care about babies
but this money this program is not going
to help a single mother
get
a baby food as i understand it right
this is this is for the farmers markets
the free vegetables the tomatoes that
sort of thing this is not the baby
formula crisis right
or wrong can they can they go to a
farmer's market and buy baby formula
no um you can't buy baby formula if i
can speak i think
not speaking for senator whitley but i
think we're talking about alleviating
some of the financial burden um i think
that neither tiffany nor i should speak
to what the department can do
understanding that is vitally important
and it's a great program for our state
so if there is a middle ground between
what senator whitley is suggesting and
what you are suggesting representative
edwards as advocates we really implore
you to consider that
follow
okay so
so this isn't just about fiscal
responsibility this is about
operational uh possibility this is the
the art of the doable here is to give
them the money to get ready for next
july because because as i understand it
these coupons need to be redeemed
within the july one and i forget if it
was september 1 or september 30
and if we fall outside of that deadline
then there they can't use the coupons in
in the current few months is
which is september 1 or september 30. i
don't recall
september 30 i believe it is yes
so just to complete my thought
um
senator whitley i i like this program i
think you and i've worked on similar
programs
and i i can assure you that from my
research and talking to people that if
we put seed money in for the
administrative overhead
it wouldn't have to it would you know 30
000 would be a lot but
but
this isn't about being cheap this is
just about it takes time to stand up a
program and re reality should
interject itself into what we're doing
yeah thank you and and i definitely
appreciate that my only hesitation it's
two things one it's possible that the
department can get going and i and i
know well i do know that because
there are we already have snap farmers
market program and so we already have a
vendor that does that now and so that
same vendor could just do it for wic
so we have a vendor that could do it so
my proposal would be at 100 000 um and
that that would give us enough if if
they were able to stand it up by
september right then there would be
money available if people were able to
go to the farmers market
and again i'm just i'm just a no at any
amount over 30 000 because i i really
did try to research this and understand
it because i i i want to respect you and
when it came to my committee i wanted to
make sure i knew what i was talking
about and so i'm i'm i'm trying to
respect your position without while
respecting the reality of what it takes
to get a program like this up and
operational 30 000 is the most i could
go
representative hunt your thoughts
senator greg
well
certainly
it appears to me
is a reasonable amount and the senate
can
support that i believe
that you know we not only have to look
at the amount of time
can we
you know get the coupons out for this
year
can
well i understand
representative edwards you say no
but i think that there are a lot of
motivated people out there who want to
do the right thing
for these mothers and children
and giving them the assets that they
need to do that
i believe is the right thing to do
and so my opinion
and from the nods that i've gotten from
my colleagues
uh that the senate position would be
that the hundred thousand dollars is the
is the appropriate amount
the senator attributed this statement to
me
but i'm passing on what i've been told
by the people who would run this program
they can't get the rfis they can't get
the coupons they can't get the marketing
out they can't hit
september 30th this year but they can
prepare and get ready for july one of
next year so uh it that's not me that's
the research and the people who i talk
to about it
okay
again representative hunt how high would
you go starting with zero and going to
three hundred thousand pick a number
i would uh support my fellow
representative when he makes a
recommendation because he knows more
about this than i do 15 000
they can't spend all the 30 anyway
the other option is to actually hold
just for a little bit on this and
actually get lisa roy you know ask if
she can come and really give us some
confirmation
[Music]
we have other things to talk about maybe
she could well we do but
um
i'm not ready to budge above 30 000
either
so that's we'll come back to that after
we've had a minute to chew on it i mean
i think the program is a good one but
for right now
okay
item next in your printout it is page
three
um it's another senate add-on its
association health plans
pilot program
anyone wish to speak to that
yes let me speak to that
so um this uh piece of legislation uh
was in my committee commerce committee
and um i think it was almost unanimously
uh
voted inexpedient
and uh
in
for several reasons one is that uh we
already have a statute similar in place
to allow alliances to be formed
but more importantly the idea of
limiting it i mean it turned to turn the
whole alliance thing upside down
because it had a limited amount of
members
which is only has the potential of
creating an adverse selection process
and even more bizarre was that it was a
pilot program because
if you're going to put one of these
together it costs money to create it
and
so why would anybody put money in if
there's no guarantee that it would
continue
so
that's the reason why the commerce
committee
voted it down and and we just
i don't understand why it would reappear
today in this bill
senator
so
this was senator richard's bill i've
forgotten the number maybe
you remember the numbers um i don't know
why we wouldn't do it
it
excuse me for a thousand
um insured lives
it's a small number in the overall
scheme of things it would help us answer
you know questions potentially as to
whether
associated health plans would have some
merit in new hampshire
you may be right there may be no takers
we've had this conversation
um but
i don't know why we wouldn't do it so i
think the senate wants to
have this deal because we already have
that one we already have a lot right but
i understand the miwa law but
um it hasn't happened this
is affirmative in that the department of
insurance would um
develop and implement a pilot program
that's the difference
if there are no takers there are no
takers
right but
it it defies
the reason why there's no takers
with even the meal outlaws in terms of
getting that pulling that together and
making it happen
and as uh i will always remember
senator ray white's comment is that you
can't it can't be viable
given that there the risk of someone
having a a cancer or having you know had
adverse you know
somebody in the plan that you needed a
minimum of three thousand lies and
that's the reason why none of these
other he was none of these you know the
the alliance forget what we call the
other program that has never gotten
gotten off the ground
and it was because you couldn't
the risk is too great unless you really
have a critical mass to make it viable
so you're you're pointing out that it
hasn't happened and i'm saying is it
hasn't happened because
it's not economically rational
and so to put this on the books just to
have it on the books
to waste the insurance department's time
trying to put a program together and
make other insurance companies pay for
it right because it's how
it works for the insurance department to
you know for just something to be on the
books is is wasting everybody's time nor
and it's also giving the false
impression that uh this opportunity
exists you know and when when in reality
it's never going to happen when we
already have a statute well if
mr chairman if i might if you're correct
that nobody's going to bid on it it is
repealed
um
in section 5 of the bill
on july 1 of 2025 so i again i see
absolutely no harm
with the affirmative declaration that
the department should try to go forward
with it so i
i think
since we've held on section
three
i think the senate would ask we hold on
section four
oh so what do we mean by hold on what
are we holding on until continue to
discuss it okay right we won't
unilaterally eliminate it yet
it's fine with me
i don't have senate bill 286 so
therefore i don't have the fiscal note
uh
with me
if anybody does what does it say
i don't remember it happening
i don't think it had a fiscal note but
i'll look it up uh was it senate bill
286. 286 the side by side far right
column calls it 286-fn
my computer turned on it look
so technically
in terms of fiscal note
um
that
it's i'll just read a couple of things
in it the insurance department indicated
it can assume the responsibilities
associated with this bill within its
existing infrastructure with no impact
to the operating fund where the program
is limited to a thousand participants
the department assumes
the impact on premium tax if any will be
small
and in terms of appropriations there's
none in terms of revenue indeterminable
and expenditures zero
i was gonna about to say that's what i
would predict the fn would say
no it's not it's you know in terms of
the department's energy it's really
it's just gonna sit there anyways
because they know they know too they
know better than i do that
this is never going to be used no one's
ever going to pull this off
and
i would say that i've taken the position
many times in the commerce committee
that if we actually had somebody coming
forward
viably wants
a legislation when even comes to the
idea of buying health insurance across
state lines i say show me that one
insurance company who wants to sell it
across state lines show me somebody who
really is going to put this plan
together that has a viable market plan
you know has a plan to make it happen
then then the commerce committee would
absolutely jump with joy and pass it but
at this point you know we've we've
already been down this path so many
times we know
it's it's
not reality
so you'll be a no
i would be a no okay
and
having studied medical studies a little
bit
and having listened to some conversation
about this i would agree that a thousand
participants is
unwise
it's too small
so that'd be a no as well so i think
that kills this section
and the last section is
it starts on the bottom of page three at
uh day number seven
medicaid enhancement for children and
pregnant women
anyone wish to kick that one off
senator yes so this is something that um
both the senate health and human
services and the how you know house
health and human services
really looked at a lot there was a lot
of discussion i know house finance also
looked at it a lot and got a lot of
testimony on it so it's
it is incredibly important right now
because it's this opportunity to extend
coverage in the medicaid program for
women from 60 days postpartum to one
year postpartum and so we know that
there's a lot of
um
data and
evidence to show that you know if we can
keep moms healthy and keep them healthy
by uh affording them coverage we're also
keeping babies healthy and so you know
for a whole host of
reasons access to coverage is incredibly
important for women postpartum so it's
an opportunity from the federal
government i think we really have to
take advantage of
could i could the chair ask
representative webber to do a little
look up to see how our committee did
when this bill came to us please thank
you representative edwards
you know
i don't know
407.
senate bill yeah
thank you
of course she does yeah and i'm sorry
for
i would like to know how the um health
and human services committee of the
house voted on this
i do remember that now yes
okay
and while you got that up would you
division three i think probably passed
at 7-0
i i'm thinking
okay that's finance but
so what happened is just what happened
yeah you attached house bill 1210
so you supported the program
the house did sorry thank you
that was representative lang's vaccine
bill which
had a lot of debate so
we
didn't concur with that bill
and we
attached
the medicaid piece to this bill
that's what happened
thank you
so in summary
it sounds like the house position on
this is that the two relevant committees
heard it agreed with it it went to the
house floor and i believe we passed this
uh just like a week ago
is that there's a researcher back here
what what what was the house vote on
this
so the house position is we passed this
through committee through committee
through the floor
so this is the house position that
i know from being married to a doctor
there's this
lack of coming in when you should have
mr orm is patient
because you didn't want to pay the copay
now it has gotten very expensive and you
feel like bleep
so pay me now pay me more later
representative edwards so so just to put
this in context uh there was there this
is only picking up an additional 10
months for a wedge of of uh clients or
patients
it's it's those that are above
some percentage i think i i don't
remember it exactly maybe it was 140
percent of the federal poverty up until
298 percent or 296 percent something
under 300 percent and in that wedge
there was an estimate that that would
include
570 approximately
women that wouldn't have otherwise been
covered
and then i think i recall that we
anticipated about a quarter of them
would actually need the services and
we'd be spending more money so so um so
we're not we're not solving the world
we're not boiling the ocean we're just
trying to help a relatively limited
number of people
get the additional postpartum care so
i i think given the house position i i
can support it
representative hunt
don't have any problems
with supporting it but um
other than i guess it's this games we
have things getting moved around from
one bill to another it's a little
tiresome because i went through this on
friday
and um uh
before you go there
four of my bills
were taken
um under advisement by the house and a
lot of things added to it so john please
i understand
okay
we share each other's tiredness
senator gray
i
think that the house accepting the
senate's position
okay well working backwards then
starting with this one
we are all
both groups senate and house yes on
medicaid enhancement for children
yeah
yeah yeah yes yes yes
yeah we actually
decided to vote yeah okay
so now let's go backwards and
look at
four and three i think there were some
trade-offs in mind here or something um
mr chair if i may yes please
i think we could um accept something
between
30 and 100
so
here's what i'd suggest mr chair okay
why don't we
um i need to give some thought
with representative hunt to
the associated plan piece
um why don't you think about what you
could live with between 30 and
and we come back in a day or two okay
all right so we can hold on to
um
and now the pilot sorry
and three
and hold on free
okay
back to
one
the
no person shall be required to receive a
covet back to receive service from dhhs
i don't think any of us have any trouble
with that the question is do we need it
because we both passed it and we'll pass
it
that's my plan if it's good once let's
do it twice but okay well actually third
time charles well that's charm then sir
yes
representative i i just want to go back
to the horse trading idea over a number
between 30 and 100 000.
i i swear to god the amount of money
that they need to get this program
started is is
less than 30
any more that we put in there
is one of two things is going to happen
one it's just not going to get spent
because they can't spend it that much on
getting the program started and getting
the coupons printed
or worse they spend it on something else
and it's wasted or at least it's not
authorized so i didn't i'm not like just
picking 30 000 out of the air
uh it
you know that that just seems to me to
be the the maximum reasonable amount
that we should go to but
we can take a couple days to think about
it
uh and if i may miss chair
uh
if we're gonna wait two days anyway
uh certainly that will give us time to
bolster our argument that the money can
be spent
and that we will would request that time
to be able to do that consult with the
department
and try to make it say win-win for the
state and the mothers and children
if we go to recess we need to
well i have a 10
well it's 12.
it's 12. i have another one that's going
to be recessed they don't know it yet
if a committee of conference meeting
recesses
the reconvening time should be posted on
the general court with 12 hours notice
and is this not a committee of
conference
that's not what i'm reading in front of
me that was sent to me the key thing to
read
is that when it comes time to schedule
you it has to be 12 hours
so
if you uh you know in terms of
i'll use whatever word is listed to get
whatever it is we want
senator can i make a suggestion you may
make a suggestion based just on
scheduling um i would propose that we
come in at 9 00 a.m on wednesday morning
i'm having eye surgery on wednesday at 9
00 a.m oh okay
if we do it later in the day my one eye
and my shoulder parrot can be present
are you sure about that no i'm not how
about tomorrow
i already have
half a dozen at least yeah so do i
i could do tomorrow like 8 30.
i could do 8 30.
8 30. okay i can do 8 30
8 30.
i could do tomorrow at nine i have
another one at night i have one at 9 30
but
well good then we'll get that pilot
program through
the end of the day you need my signature
you don't need my presence
we agreed on 8 30 for
later in the day
8 40
sometime yeah four o'clock
four o'clock
i can do four o'clock
tomorrow or today
tomorrow
and guess what that's over 24 hours
okay
yes we'll come back tomorrow at four
on 10 99 and i declare us in
recess
and i'll call a clerk thank you
let the phone calls begin
i know
i know that's why
so that she sees we fought hard for her
oh
fast i know it is
okay
it is 10 o'clock and this is the
committee of conference for house bill
103 fn establishing a dental benefit
under the state medicaid program
and
as you know there were two different
positions on relatively minor issues
in the intervening time when we
requested a committee of conference we
received additional information which
made
us agree with the senate
and uh so um i would like to
uh move for the house delegation that we
exceed to the senate's position
i don't know how this works do you know
the emotion
like i can make a motion that we see
that's in a position on hb 103. make a
motion
i i i move that we proceed to the senate
position on hb 103. okay
and leon is seconding yeah so a second
and so um representative walner and i
do you agree representatives so do i
and the senate's position as you agree
with the senate position
and all all in favor say aye and sing
one verse of kumbaya and you can go off
to your next meeting senator
now i adjourn the committee of
conference on house bill 103
and wait you can't adjourn just yet
because dr finney's going to do the
chicken dance for us
dr finney is recognized for 30 seconds
and mr littman can do the hokey pokey
because that's what it's all about
welcome especially since we already
passed the language
representative weber
to your knowledge is there a quorum
requirement we have the senate here we
have us here
although
the signatures on the committee support
good thank you
okay
um
i forgot my gavel
okay thank you
dr woods is the hand surgeon you know
yes well it's close and i do and i have
a doctor too but it's in theology so
anyway uh open the committee of
conference on um house bill 1439
relative to health care facility
visitation policies and you should have
a side by side each one of us has a side
by side
and we are there's basically about three
or four items at issue and
i'm going to ask
my
policy committee vice chair
representative leon if she would
speak to those because you have
something prepared
thank you mr chairman
there are four differences between the
house and senate version the largest is
the placement
in the patient bill of rights versus in
the licensing statute i think that
that's something that the house is going
to accept moving to the patient bill of
rights because we need to move forward
on something here
additionally there's a documentation
need so the house viewed that it was
very important that if there was a
patient who was contraindicated for
visitors that there was actually a
patient specific reason for that
contraindication for visitors and as
such if there was a contraindication
something would already be charted and
it would make sense to
note that the patient
what had their visitors asked to leave
because they had a significant event
that contraindicated those visitors
that's something that we are willing to
set aside at this point because
we are more important we're
much more concerned about the two other
ones the first letting people know that
we've heard their voice we've heard too
many people that didn't have access to
their loved ones and simply adding the
four words at the beginning of this
section on the patient bill of rights no
patient left alone
will be a nice touchstone for those
people who have
had a traumatic past two years this
trauma has been in the healthcare
facilities with our heroes that have
been working on the front lines it's
also been in our families and in our
community
and we need to come together um and and
heal this and move forward so um the
first part would be to replace
um the first section
and just add the words no patient left
alone right after xxi xxiii i
that would show up
in
right on page one of the side by side on
the senate side between the xxii and the
a we would add the words no patient left
alone and hopefully that is something
that we can all agree upon in order to
just understand where everyone is coming
from the other section is really a
de-escalation issue
there are conflicts over visitation
policies and the easiest way to calm a
conflict is to be able to hand something
to somebody in black and white and say
hear the rules we're not doing anything
different for you these are the rules to
keep people safe
please read through them let me know if
you have a problem and then we can
discuss it but the rules are written and
they are here
the house had
had said that we were going to place
both the patient bill of rights and the
written hospital policy on the wall of
patient treatment rooms
we don't really need to wallpaper the
rooms but we do need to make it very
clear that this information is available
so we have the language to
put a notif an informational sign in all
patient treatment rooms to make the
patients and visitors aware of the
contents of this
the section of the patient bill of
rights
oh sorry aware of the contents of the
patient's bill of rights and their right
to receive a current printed copy of the
written hospital visitation policies
upon request
this is a great way when somebody starts
getting a little bit agitated
you hand them a copy and say you'll be
back
we we went through a lot of work on
senate bill 459 for de-escalation to
reduce workplace violence and i believe
that this would go hand-in-hand with
that so i believe that these are two
very important changes
but i think that they still
honor the request to move this to the
patient bill of rights and to not add
any documentation requirements to our
stressed health care system today
thank you
in talking with various members of the
house health and human services
committee
i was particularly
happy to hear from
dr
woods i used his title deliberately
retired i think president of new
hampshire medical society a hand surge
and so on and he thought there was merit
again not to wallpaper the room with all
the rules but to have the salient ones
posted in each room with a reference to
where they can be found online there
they are we're not hiding anything we're
not saying you got to go out and punch
up something on your computer but basic
things are there
i also recall we were told that oh the
hospitals are pretty compliant with
these things and my response whenever
i'm given that statement is then you
have nothing to fear if you're already
doing a good job now you get extra
credit because it's posted so
um i would agree certainly very much
with that um i know from being part-time
chief executive officer of a small
medical facility when a certain thing
happens it's important to document it
and if a patient is told you can't
do such and such
regarding visitors or visitors told that
put it on the chart rather than relying
on somebody's memory
later on that this might or might not
have uh taken place again it's
that with the title of this is
de-escalation as i said in the house
hearing
being clergy i have 47 years i've been
in hospitals a lot visiting a lot of
people and for the most part they do a
wonderful job they do try to accommodate
there are occasions when visitors are
unruly and need
to be dealt with there are other times
when an overstressed staff occasionally
misses something that they should have
done for the most part things have run
incredibly well so i come to the
hospital visitation policy bill uh not
hostile at all to the hospital but very
much wanting to um just let people know
who are overstressed that you've been
heard you've been valued senators
um
thank you mr chair and i would uh first
of all uh i really appreciate
the
keeping this in the patient bill of
rights rather than going into licensure
actually in the patient bill of rights
it may actually have more clout
because the licensure body looks at
technical issues but in terms of
comprehensive nature and compliance with
your own policies
that's where you get into accreditation
which actually has more clout than
licensure if you're not accredited if
you're not accredited by cms you're in
trouble as a hospital you're not viable
and they look to
being compliant with your patient bill
of rights um whereas it's only the state
with licensure that would be like
looking at if it were sitting in license
for so i really appreciate
that um recognition of where this is
going to have the most impact and where
it sits most
um
comfortably
i think the no patient left alone act
um i
this to me
i understand where it comes from
but no frontline healthcare worker over
the last two years has
ever
left a patient alone
what we're really trying to do is to
make sure that under all potential
circumstances unless there's some really
uh overweening reason why it can't
happen
the patient should not be without their
loved ones with people who care about
them but this is so broad
that it's almost like no patient should
continue to be neglected
and
as a
physician who's practiced for over 30
years hospital-based medicine
to me
this really could be taken and i know
it's not meant to be but it could be
taken as being incredibly inflammatory
and offensive
so if we can rephrase it in a way that
really targets what the bill is trying
to do that would say
i know it's not very very um
the word smithing is would need to be
done but
um i would prefer it to say
no patient without their loved ones
unless there's a really
no
qualified
competent physician nurse lna
would ever leave a patient alone in fact
in covid when there were these really
tough provider issues and and visitation
issues
we had i mean the the visuals of cmc
where the the
people were the nurses were doing
signage back and forth and with the
families who couldn't come in and making
sure their loved ones had that
this to me doesn't capture the
commitment on the part of the
workers in the hospitals
and how much they care deeply about the
patients and making sure that their
loved ones can be there
so if we can come up with different
language i have no problem re-inserting
this but i do have a problem with these
words because i think it
it
it's brought too broad
in that it also could say
don't neglect patience which
does not happen and it actually would be
malpractice so we shouldn't be
having something in statute that uses
those words in my book and that
and i see lucy has her hands up uh but
the
the other
one that
i was concerned about is
how we
let patients know i would prefer
a system where
patients are provided with information
on admission
that they can have with them you know
there is a packet most hospitals and
paulo or steve can help me with this
i know my hospital has a bi-fold packet
that has all the patient information in
it
you could either have that bi-fold
packet that actually would have
visitation policy on it
you know as a part of the printed packet
on the inside maybe that's very
prominent
you could have that bifold packet that
also showed where to go online for it
[Music]
many and one thing i'd add to this but
because i think it's really a great idea
many patients don't know that every
hospital has a patient advocate
so having how to access the patient
advocate
in that same information packet that
would go with the patient to the room it
would give them how to do a daily update
on visitation the family would have
access to it
but it would again get away from the
idea of wallpapering
the rooms
which actually can get into sanitation
issues
some of these rooms if you
they're very careful about
what they put where especially in a room
that has
ventilation to prevent say the spread of
covet or tb or other airborne diseases
so my preference would be to have
if you're going to have required notice
and you want to broaden it
let's use a vehicle that's already there
which is
this packet that's given at the
beginning of every hospitalization i'd
need to ask paul and steve what they
thought of that but
it would just be expanding what's
already given to the patient by
virtually every hospital
and then it moves with the patient so it
sits at their bedside it's accessible
and it'll be something the nurse could
then print out and give to them if
there's any question
and also senator while you're up um the
fourth item would be the
reason for denial of a visitor
for medical or therapeutic
contraindication should be documented
documented in the patient's medical
record um that was something the
original sponsor wanted what do you
think about that
um
well you know
we already document so much and i'm not
sure that's
the clinical record is really for the
clinical record it's not it's not for
that if
um
i don't see that as being something that
uh is appropriate in the clinical record
um the only place i could see it
possibly going would be in the nurses
notes
but then it would get
kind of lost in those so i you know i i
would
in my world having worked with emrs
they're all different they all have
different templates
um
and if you are having to put in
visitation policy in your emr
it's yet another thing and if you ask
any health care professional
you know what the emr is for it's for
things that are clinically appropriate
for the patient so i would prefer to not
have it in the emr is there another
place where it could be documented
there might be you know
[Music]
but i would
i'm wondering if there might be some
middle ground if you feel very strongly
on it that
at a
patient's request or at the discretion
of the nurse rather than having it
happen every single time
that if a patient requested it it could
be put in the nurse's notes
the reason for it
but i think of it as one more thing we
have to document and i don't know
why it would be clinically necessary or
appropriate
and i also don't really know
what's going to be what that information
is going to be used for
in the future so
my guess would be if there is an issue
understood we already have a mechanism
for that if you look at
the uh and paulo or steve could probably
explain this or um
you know anybody from the hospitals
could explain
this role of the patient advocate when
we do have an issue we have people in
mind
in my hospital we have somebody who'll
come up interview the patient and then
we'll start
uh an actual file that would track with
that patient but it doesn't go into the
medical record it goes into something
that is
uh
you know legal that's accessible and
it's a document that goes along with the
patient advocate
so but to
have an every time re you know
documentation of something that
likely will
never
be needed but if it is needed we have a
mechanism all ready to document that
through the patient advocate program
and i believe that's a requirement of
cms
or accreditation that you have to have a
department of patient advocate in every
hospital is that correct
or do you know
okay every hospital i've ever worked in
has had that role
um
so that might be a better place for this
and that could also be explained in that
initial packet that we go out
senator bradley this is the opening
salvo here
senator bradley
well i i agree with senator sherman i'm
glad that this is staying in the patient
bill of rights in terms of the emergency
medical records
i have the same concern that
senator sherman has
from a slightly different perspective i
guess i think we all know
that
just the amount of hours that
staff is having to work now
asking to do one more thing
um undermines patient care
when there ought to be whether it's
through the patient advocate or not um
some other way of doing it than
having
um
nurses or whomever always document in
emr
this at a time that we're having a hard
time hiring people so
i
would be opposed to doing it in the form
that it is
it's suggested here
and of the other three items we're
looking at the title the build sponsor
wanted it no patient left alone act i'm
sure wordsmiths in the room
have a great alternative in fact i think
i'd like to call on representative
weber
that is the important thing
and
obviously i think
we don't want to imply that they're
abandoned we want
them to have the best support
i put down patient visitation act but i
like yours better it's warmer
senator bradley that okay with you
senate patient support act
again i think
senator sherman and i work closely and
carefully with
the hospital association i'd want them
to look at any proposed language change
i mean these are their buildings
and the stress upon our
medical workers and our hospitals as
institutions has been
significant over the last couple of
years and so i think
we need to make sure that
we're not out thinking them
and i think it's important that they
look at this language and get back to us
i mean i would just note that the
sheet that
um representative leon
gave me with the exception of the title
the language is identical so
um
i'm not sure where the big issue is
page three uh senator bradley under um
information that is posted the question
as to whether the policy should be
online only
or should be posted
and
senator sherman
gave
another
yeah no i would agree with senator
sherman look i was told
that
sometimes these visitation policies
during cove would change multiple times
in a short period of time so
again whether i think senator sherman
brought up a good point about sanitation
i go back to
you know the actual workers being over
stressed were
they're being asked to do more with less
it seems like if we can refer people to
an updated policy change on a website or
hand them a piece of paper
that hasn't updated then you're not
having to
you know go through large hospitals
re-paper every room it just doesn't make
any sense to me
okay we've i've heard from three let me
weigh in a little bit here
um
it sounds like do we have consensus on
patient support act as the name
i love that name
okay so we're good on that one
um
well again again
i want
i mean we can tentatively
say we're okay
but i don't think myself i'm not signing
off on anything until the actual
language has been reviewed by you know
the people that run the 26
hospitals i'll be talking we'll be
talking and listening in a minute
i'm just looking at us
we seem to
agree
that something should be documented
somewhere
in case there's a refusal
and a refusal
that could be escalating
and a refusal that could lead to a
lawsuit and
having been asked on a couple of
occasions as a clergyman visiting a
hospital information about what went
down i know what went down and what i
said i saw was written down somewhere
and i think that was to protect numerous
not just the patient the visitor but the
hospital too
so we are looking at where is the best
place
for that i think it would be helpful to
again
talk to the hospitals before we move
forward with this i feel very strongly
the electronic medical record is not the
appropriate place
this is not a clinic i don't want to
minimize the therapeutic benefit of
having
family clergy and visitors it's really
important but it
this kind of legal documentation
i don't believe has any place in the emr
and just like senator bradley said it's
one more thing
on every patient
that they have to document on the other
hand
i would defer to the hospitals do they
already have a mechanism
for when there is an issue with a
patient or with visitation or any issue
where do they already put that
in terms of their hospital documentation
i think that's what we need to get at
and if it already exists
i don't want to reinvent the wheel and
put that also in statute if there
already is a place for them to do that
i would leave that alone
the chair would like to call up miss
minihan and mr
rahern so we can uh
ask you these questions directly and
hear what you have to say
so i'll walk you through what i just
walked ourselves
through um
as you know there's a back story there's
a lot of back stories behind this bill
and waving off certain parts
isn't can be inflammatory and i don't
want that i don't want it in my center
and believe me we've had conversations
with
our staff as to maybe it's a little bit
more work maybe it's a pain in the neck
maybe the patient is a pain in the neck
i'm trying to defuse things here at the
same time i don't want
to
over burden unnecessarily so
patient support act
it seems to be in some form quite
important to people
um thank you representative um for the
record paula manhan um for the hospital
association ann
steven hospital association
and you know with respect to patient
support act i i agree with senator
sherman um sort of the notion of leave
no patient alone
signals something that we're not doing
we're not leaving our patients alone and
that's not what this is about so patient
support act i don't have any real issues
with um i mean this is in the patient's
bill of rights um so it's all about
patient's support um so i i don't think
i have
a real concern about that um i'm not
overly con
certain that it's necessary but if
there's a belief that that's
uh an important point and i understand
the importance of visitation nobody
needs to
convince me about the importance of that
but at the same time we have to
recognize that you know there are times
when we can't always do exactly
everything that we would like
to ensure the health and safety of our
patients our staff and our communities
and and unfortunately you know that
tension um certainly um you know ran
headlong into one another um during this
period and i understand that um but i
think again what we're trying to do is
to ensure that we can
have patients visited by their families
and loved ones in the best way possible
in the safest way possible but as we've
said there are times when
we will need some flexibility um to to
ensure the health and safety of our
patients and our staff
and our visitors and and we believe that
you know certainly the the senate uh
language comes much closer to that um so
as it relates to patients uh safety act
uh patient support support i'm i'm i'm
i'm okay okay senator sherman you want
to jump in on this yeah i just wanted to
ask a question you know
jumping forward can i ask about the emr
question i'd like to take it in order
okay i'll wait but hold that thought um
the second item is it should go
uh where should it go um
patient bill of rights
did we like
yes the patient bill of rights works we
like that so we're in agreement on that
that's where it should be placed in the
law okay so we're down to two and we're
two for two
and we're encouraged
now
um
reason for denial of a visitor i know
from living with this daily that we've
had
occasions that were untoward
and we wrote it down somewhere
and i think emr is probably not the
place i wish i'd asked my wife where do
we put that information but we put it
somewhere so where would be the best
place for a documentation of this
i guess our concern is and i think
senator sherman um touched on it as did
senator bradley we need flexibility and
i think i have been consistent
throughout the entire process dealing
with this bill hospitals need
flexibility what exeter hospital has
might be very different than what
dartmouth hitchcock has versus a small
critical access hospital
in wolfeboro so that's our concern is i
don't think honestly it needs to be here
because it needs to be in statute
because they're already doing that
so
we
to put it in statute we will need to go
back to find out what it would be called
but i think senator sherman made another
good point that they have patient
advocates i mean i have worked with
hospitals um when there are issues that
they do have a patient advocate that
gets involved um and they help with that
whole entire process so again to be
prescriptive is a problem um because
they they um they need that flexibility
because not every hospital um functions
the same
dr sherman so if we just walk through
this bill
um the first
iteration
we have to document
why there's a denial
in the heat of covid when things were at
their worst or even
last november when we were with the
delta surge
we had blanket policies across
the entire hospital no visitors i don't
know if we did that back i think we did
that both times but certainly in the
height of the pandemic
about a year and a half ago
there were no visitors allowed in my
hospital 104
or over 100 beds
and we were surging so we had probably
100 130 patients
that would have meant that the nurse
would have had to write in every emr
dead
the reason for denial is
this is cdc
guidelines this is coming from the dhhs
or whatever
that to me is unworkable
putting it in
the second part would be
what would be something short of that if
there's a dispute well first of all we
know that you all have documentation of
your hospital visitation policies like
that it's it's in the record of the
hospital
so if there were any litigation which
has been brought up the hospital has the
records and the justification for their
hospital their hospital-wide policy
again
no specific patient-based documentation
needed
then you get down to the specific
patient based problems
when those disputes arise or if there's
an incident
part of that is what we're trying to get
at with workforce safety
healthcare workforce safety and
unfortunately i will remind this body
that the
the uh compulsory nature of the
commission and of reporting was removed
by the house
you know that
that
we had coming from the senate we had
every hospital had to participate and
that was removed by the house i believe
in the final version so it becomes more
voluntary i i may be incorrect but that
was something that came up and that's
not really so important as much as what
we're trying to do here is make sure
that if there is an individual
issue
where do you find documentation of that
and i would propose
that we
put that off
of this bill not included in this for
two reasons number one
we have the hospital association sitting
here saying this is something that the
legislature would like to make sure
is somewhere in the documentation of the
hospital and your homework assignment
for
so we don't end up having to put it in
statute is to find out where that is
make sure it's uniform across all the
hospitals i suspect that that is part of
your accreditation process and that
having an ability for a patient to bring
a concern forward and have that
documented as part of accreditation
because i served on the regulatory
committees my hospitals
but i don't think we need to put in
statute especially if it already exists
and i do believe for the reasons i've
already stated that the emr is the wrong
place for it
um
sorry yes yes
sorry um i would agree i also um we look
at it there are always exceptions again
for
in the case of labor and delivery in the
case of end of life in the case of a
child hospitals were able to make
accommodations when appropriate but
again this was on a case-by-case basis
and you can't legislate that um that's
what's very difficult
but that is what the conditions of
participation what
cms and the joint commission and dmv
require is that they have the documented
policy so like you said where it's the
80 20 rule it's almost like the you know
99 1 rule that the exceptions um will if
we put this in the patient bill of
rights i think that could cause um some
comp confusion so
i'd like to call in representative leon
on this uh thank you mr chairman um i do
think that there's some misunderstanding
about the um about this section here
because
it states that when visitors are
non-compliant with written hospital
policy that they can be denied so that
is separate than anything that would
require documentation because if we have
a blanket ban on visiting visitors
that's already covered separately by
section d
the documentation is only for an
individualized
medical or therapeutic contraindication
if it's something that's more general to
the hospital population that would be in
the policy
this this was spoken about when somebody
was coding and there was a family member
who was thought that they might pass out
there was something that was an invasive
thing there were cleaning wounds where
they knew that it was going to be
traumatic for a visitor to watch and and
those were the types of issues that were
brought to us about these
medically or therapeutically
contraindicated for the patient so i
think this is a lot narrower than has
been interpreted but i do think that
this is something that we can figure out
how it's handled in the hospitals but
this is not a blanket documentation
requirement this is something for those
individualized cases where
where this is necessary for the patient
and then i guess i did have some other
questions but i can wait till we get to
those sections this section
that's how i rate it as well um
if somebody's threatening or violent
no emr is not where it goes but it goes
somewhere
and um i'm
of the mind that
you've
heard
what numbers of people are looking for
and
my own preference is i could live
without this specific statement
when you get back to
some committee that i chair and tell me
what you've done
and
i think it'll be good what you say but
i think people need to know what's there
understood and i guess i would just you
know sort of echo the comment that paula
made was
i'm not certain that this is something
that
needs to be in statute um you know there
are things that we can you know work
through um and i think again we're
looking as you said representatively on
sort of a narrow set of uh issues um but
again i don't know that that's um
a requirement for for for legislation or
for for something in statute um but
we're certainly willing to come back and
and talk about that
could you live with that
i can live with that okay
three for three
and the last one is
the avail the ready availability
of
the bill of rights
not wallpaper
but not oh you got to go look for it
online somewhere but somewhere in the
middle what could you live with
what i would what i would suggest is um
let us come back um
again i don't know that we need to
legislate this issue um but let us work
with the hospitals to try and figure out
what is the most
effective and efficient way of of
informing our patients of what those
policies are and how they can find more
information
senator sherman talked about
you know documentation that people get
when they come into the hospital when
they're admitted um i don't have 26
versions of those in front of me so i
can't tell you exactly what each one of
them would have but i think that's
something that we can certainly um you
know work with our members to help make
sure patients are informed of of what
those uh you know what those policies
are and how they can uh you know find
more information if if if not just
asking um you know the representative
there at the time
yes
thank you mr chairman it sounds that
this would be um an issue of hospital
policies
would it make sense to say that every
that
a written copy of the current visitation
policies will be made available upon
request consistent with hospital policy
i actually just reviewed the
conditions of participation for critical
access hospitals which are a little
different than pps hospitals but this
section is is similar
and that is a requirement already that
is why we don't believe that some of
this needs to be in statute and state
statute because they're already
complying with this um and um there are
hospital policies that's why the
hospitals have risk management
committees and um and departments to
ensure that they are um pa protecting
patients and this is all again all about
patients
and um
we can
look into that as well but i i believe
that they already make it available when
i know i've seen them when you register
um they put the patient bill of rights
up there um but i think it could also be
in the packet so i don't believe we need
to legislate this
is the one who edits the quarterly
newsletter for our medical facility
it occurred to me some years ago that
it's not enough that when my medical
staff meets at a staff meeting we know
our patients need to know what we know
and to say we have a policy
to each other
isn't enough when the patients need to
know we have a policy on this available
upon request
and so i use our newsletter as a vehicle
each quarter
to inform the patients of specific
things
we've never been challenged they trust
us they love us we do great care they
know we know but they now know what we
know
and that's the one link that's missing
that's behind this bill is this fear and
this panic and there's this and this
that
and sometimes
more communication than necessary may be
necessary
and that's what's behind this
and i personally would be willing to say
well
there was this uh political figure a
number of years ago who was asked if he
trusted the commune the communists in
ussr
and he said yes trust but verify
so to get back
on this to say here is what we're doing
or we could do
to
honor
the concerns the fears the paranoias the
whatever behind this
would go a long way
to be able to say yeah we get what
you're coming from and this is what
we're doing
and maybe we can do a little bit more i
could live with that as long as the
report comes back to me fairly quickly
because this legislation file period in
the fall
and if on these two items
there isn't adequate response which
i don't expect i think there will be
adequate response but if there isn't
then we can file a bill and we'll know
why we can file it so i mean that would
be my deal
that i could live with
i'd still like to have the written stuff
have it clear that the patient is able
to get the written policy and the
patient advocate information upon
request in some way consistent with
hospital policies without dictating the
requirements
and i would just suggest representative
leon that that is redundant
because i think it's already provided
and i would just need a couple a few
minutes to just find it but i i believe
that it is already that is already um
provided upon request so it's somewhat
redundant um i don't know that the bill
needs to be amended to incorporate that
that would
but my one question is if the patients
know that they can request that
can i i can't speak neither can you for
every patient but um it is like i said
we it is posted um when they are going
through the admission process and it
probably is in the in the packets that
they also receive when they're um
admitted but i i have to confirm that
and i would just suggest you know
putting it in state statute doesn't
necessarily mean that that patient would
be more informed um so again as i
suggested you know let us work with our
members to you know ensure that that
information is being provided and if we
come back and and we tell you that
that's not happening then you'll have a
an opportunity to move forward on
something else um but again i i i
believe that you know our members want
to do everything they can to ensure
their patients you know get the right
care at the right time at the right
place and the right way and that they're
supported throughout that process that's
that's what we are committed to doing
that's what our members are committed to
doing um and again you know we're happy
to come back and share that information
with you
whichever version of this is accepted
today
will include
the words each healthcare facility
license pursuant to rsa 151 colon 2
shall post on its website and it lists a
bunch of things you're going to have
that
whichever version we agree to
would just suggest some of us are just
suggesting it might be teased out a
little bit more specifically for the
patient and you're going to come back
and say
this is what you have been doing you
might even want to say and pursue into
this conversation
plus we're going to do this as well
and that would be very helpful and
remember we're dealing with fears
and they have a reality of their own and
we all want to
defang them as much as we can
we all want we all want to find ways to
work of course we do and remember i deal
with this daily
well i think we're there
are we there
um
patient support act we agree with
yes
okay
uh it's in the patient's bill of rights
we agree with that
uh we are going to
punt on the reason for denial but
they're going to get back to us on that
and we are going to
punt
on exactly other than the website the
information is available and they're
going to get back to us on that
so in those last two cases we would
agree with the
senate's version
are we there i'm assuming that
the information is in fact provided i'm
i'm great with that if we find out that
there's a lack i definitely appreciate
support in passing this next year if we
need to do something and if that's the
case then i can agree with this today
so i think we're
done good thank you everybody
i'll go down to ols and
walk them through what we're doing
it succeed to senate on points three and
four
actually i think it is exceed the senate
on two
um i think it would simply be inserting
the words patient support act um and i
can figure out exactly the lines that's
the only change that's the only
um that's what i have senator okay okay
good we're done thank you
wow yep
welcome back
to call in to session the committee of
conference
meeting on house bill
and
would you
[Music]
this is the mother of side by sides
and it explains the fact that we have
four parts
to this bill
now
and
i would like to go through each section
bit by bit to see
where we are on them
the first part establishes a data
privacy an information technology
security governance board within dhhs to
oversee data privacy risk calculation
and risk mitigation efforts and provides
for two employees with the department to
accomplish these objectives
one of my joys is chairman of the joint
legislative dhhs
oversight committee is watching the
development of this program under
representative edwards
we had at least three of our monthly
meetings in part devoted to this because
we want to do two things at once if
possible number one provide usable
helpful data and number two make sure
the security is the best it can be and
with those two
necessities how can it happen so i'm
going to ask representative edwards to
say a few words about uh
what he pulled off
uh uh thank you mr chair i this is
really a great team effort with the
department and with the department of
i.t
uh
both
departments have shown strong support
for the idea of establishing a privacy
functional capability within
their departments
um
i i think uh
that there's a lot to 1662 that they
could choose to do on their own without
the legislation
but if we were to not pass 1662
the issue with that would be that um the
funding to to create two new positions
with entirely new skill sets would not
happen and what is the new skill set you
really need to have somebody who
understands cyber security understands
uh privacy principles and understands
business process flows so that they can
identify weaknesses and and come up with
mitigation strategies for them and the
department when they've tried to do
these privacy impact assessments have
had to rely on contractors so they they
have even the capability today to do the
entire bill but
but the
creating the in-house staff
would
start to develop institutional
knowledge and memory and and would just
move the department along faster so i i
think it's a good bill i hope we can
support it if if we can it's not the end
of the world
unless i missed something in the big
side by side there is no difference
between the senate and the house
so it sounds like the senate's position
the house was positioned on this is
already
known so if there is no objection do we
sign off on
part one of what we have before us
i don't see
any any questions while
representative edwards is on this topic
okay good thank you
the second section of this is found on
the very bottom of page five it is
housing expenses for homeless people and
appropriation five million dollars and
you will see that this is carved up
amongst the various towns in the next
multiple of pages
and that's senator khan i believe that
is your project if you can speak to that
please sir
thank you mr chairman
um so
the
first debate that occurred on
homelessness funding for the biennium
took place around house bill 2.
the department of health and human
services
housing security
proposed a dollar amount
and
that was essentially halved
during
the appropriation process so the amount
of funding is significantly less in the
biennium than what was originally
requested and that was the motivation of
bringing this to the senate
the
so it's it's essentially the same it
started as the same bill as what was
requested by hhs for housing support for
the biennium
we've passed fiscal 22 so let's focus on
fiscal 23.
arpa rent subsidies are ending
and
the availability and affordability of
housing
those problems continue to persist
they're not going to go away anytime
soon
it is a central part of the governor's
task force on uh the council on housing
stability
to
try to provide greater assistance to
towns and shelters for homelessness
and to help people
avoid of getting into
that kind of situation
so originally the senate
on the bill that i proposed tabled the
bill
uh
and
the reason was that the route for
distributing the dollars was suggested
in same way as it was for a house bill 2
an allocation that would go to the
department and the department would
distribute it to the contracted shelters
the 40 contracted shelters that the
department has existing agreements with
the disagreement in the senate
conversation was that's not providing a
wide enough distribution across the
state that in fact there are towns that
are experiencing costs related to
homelessness or housing and security
that are being born in every town
and that
we needed to find a mechanism for that
distribution i'd been working with
representative umberger
on trying to find a substitute for free
and reduced lunch
and that substitute that we've talked
about is medicaid
eligibility and
enrollments
so the department of health and human
services uh has
a mechanism for reporting that by town
to the legislative budget assistant and
that's where the april 3rd
237 lives covered by medicaid is the
source
for identifying which towns how much
eligibility they might have
we arrived at a 5 million we were
working with a 5 million dollar request
and then distributed that 5 million
dollars based on medicaid enrollments
by town
as of april 3rd
those enrollments uh
there's not a
town that doesn't have a couple dozen
people who are medicaid eligible and
enrolled
so
it does distribute dollars to every
all 234
of our towns
and it does so in a manner that the
towns have local control
this is not just prescribed to the 40
towns that at 40 shelters
under which have contracts
this is allocated two towns
now towns
i've started following uh representative
edwards
thought pattern
towns are helped
help
homeless and people in risk of
homelessness in a variety of ways it's
either through rent subsidies
uh mortgage uh
subsidy
because if a person is in risk of losing
their home
that's a taxable property that's going
to go into default and the town is going
to lose that those dollars so i i've
been on a city council that's what we
did uh
that was that's another way those are
the direct routes the indirect routes
are the towns make payments to homeless
shelters and to other community service
housing agencies that provide housing
assistance that might include community
action programs across the state or
women's violence protection just to give
you a couple and and i happen to check
with your towns
to see
uh what they are doing uh as far as
making payments from their town budgets
to either direct subsidy or
indirect subsidy through payments
through third parties
and each of them is doing all the above
[Music]
so in summary i think we've got a
solution
to an issue
uh that is going to persist into the
fiscal 23 year
we
have estimates from the department that
this is fifteen hundred people
who are homeless
in the state
during this last season
we have estimates from the department of
education that say that there are four
thousand school-age children who
experience homelessness in the course of
the school year
uh and we only have 965 sheltered beds
uh so this problem is going to persist
and if it's not in your town today uh
amen
but this is a
a relief valve
and
it enables your town to contribute to
some bigger efforts in your counties
which no doubt are being paid for
with local monies
so that's the
that's the position of the senate when
this came to a vote
uh fairly recently as an amendment on
uh it passed unanimously on a roll call
vote 24 to nothing
so i we've achieved that bipartisan
buy-in to this i hope we can do that in
in this
committee of conference thank you
any questions for the senator
representative edwards
uh thank you mr chair uh senator khan
you and i had a chance to talk about
this the other night and since then i've
been trying to
continue to come up to speed on this is
as i understand it the the state for
more than the past budget cycle
has had a fund where it could res
we could have the governor's budget put
money into an account
that would be authorized to to
be spent in the manner that your bill
prescribes
and i just want to verify with you if
you think that that's true that there
has
been for more than one budget cycle an
account
that the governor could have funded
that
would have met this purpose
i'm going to i think there are people
here could we can we ask that of uh
somebody from hhs
it's up to you more familiar
it's up to the chair
somebody from hhs
that would be you
you are indeed somebody thank you thank
you chris
it is now
good afternoon chris antonello
department of health and human services
associate commissioner i think
if i'm understanding your question
correctly um representative edwards um
the department has for the last two
um
by budget request requested dollars for
shelters
um specifically for shelter services so
that money would be added to our
contract line to go to shelters this is
a little different and that has not been
funded for an increase in that this is a
little different because it would go to
the communities and
i think one of the benefits of it going
to the
towns and cities is it really
could be used um to keep people housed
right because that's ultimately what we
want to do is have people remain
um in their
um where they are how so they don't
become homeless
follow follow up okay so you just taught
me something you've you taught me the
distinction between what we've had for a
few years which is money
in a homeless shelter program and that
this is distinct in that this is money
that can go straight to the towns and
we've not done that in the past correct
and towns depending on the community um
could choose to give that money to a
local shelter they could use it to help
keep people you know in their um place
of residence so our money today
we have at the department goes out in
contracts to support the shelters once
people need a shelter oh okay so um so
this takes me in two directions one if
it's
if it's general funds does it lapse on
january on june 30th of 2023
in other words
if if the governor uses general funds
does are we creating a use it or lose it
kind of situation for the towns that
that's that's one part
so
i'm going to look at
john who left um i believe
don't leave me here john you got me i
believe that general funds do lapse
unless they it is
indicated differently in the footnote
and there's nothing in the legislation
that prevents that thanks john
good job mr williams oh okay so so just
so you know i have a little concern
there about uh this is a new program for
the towns it's use it or losing money
you know it's probably it's just sort of
setting them up to fail because they
don't really know how to spend this kind
of money when the state has given it to
them so we would distribute it um by
there's a date here i want to say august
1st we would um put
when we distribute it what it would be
used for i do think
um
we could look to add something about
reporting so we would know how people
are spending it and also i think what's
key in this bill is really um we already
are partnering um with the um local
welfare administrators and that's been
really successful and we would actually
put that in any
letter that we put out because some of
the smaller towns probably don't even
know the work that we're doing that's in
the larger communities um and we would
really um continue to do that to help
those communities so one final so so
give us some context here this this 5
million
relative to what um division three gave
for
homelessness yeah in the in the current
biennium
you're killing me
i i'm putting you on the spot
i just want to know this 5 million is
effectively the same amount that we just
matched it or if this is a tiny fraction
of what we put into the homeless money
it's a significant portion to assisting
people
who may be experiencing homelessness i
do not have our final budget because um
it's a combination of general funds and
there's a lot of um federal funds that
we put in our budget i don't know if
senator khan knows oh good he knows oh
you you know the answer to that
oh perfect
it it the budgeted amount
per fiscal year is around three million
dollars
just for the shelter services though we
have other programs
that's my saying
other questions regarding this part of
the bill
mr chairman
if i might senator um
i've
had several follow-up conversations with
uh the department uh they have made a
few suggestions
i'm glad to hand those out to you
at this point
and
i read these suggestions as expanding
the
uses of the funds by the local
government entities
so it's not a con not putting any
further constraints on it but it's
opening it up as
chris sanello is just describing to make
sure that those people who are at risk
of homelessness
that the towns are able to address that
need very clearly in addition to the
homelessness situation
so i'll pass this yes please thank you
i have this
concern i think i share with a number
that um
i really don't like bills being attached
to other bills being attached to other
bills and especially if there's a lot of
money involved that we do have a budget
process we had one a year ago and we've
got one starting
pretty soon
and this looks like a wonderful
item for that budget but here we are in
the middle and now we've got the request
for a very large expenditure of money
and i know that because numbers of these
bills with requests for a large amount
of money are coming
i'm not quite sure what this is going to
do with either the money we want to keep
aside or the money perhaps we want to
give back to the taxpayers uh that is a
concern the issue is separate in my mind
from the general concern but this issue
falls into it in that manner it's a
procedural kind of problem that i have
if i might address that mr chairman
yeah please sir um and i i understand
your broader concern
the original request by the department
was for eight million dollars eight to
nine million dollars closer to nine
million dollars in each of the two
years of the biennium so
i
think what this is doing is for fiscal
essentially coming up to that original
request which we were unable to fund
originally in the hb2 but we do face
this wonderful
situation uh at the end of fiscal 22
looking into fiscal 23 where we've got
some resources and i think the
conversation that we've had in the
senate uh is
this is this is a great opportunity
to see a rising tide lift all boats
uh
not everybody's fortunate enough to be
lifted by some of the ideas that we've
come up with
that hopefully will
be enacted upon tax relief and things
like that
this is a means of helping those
that that we otherwise would not be and
i think it does fall into that
that that category of what were we
18 months ago or
whenever we started that budget process
what were we unable to do
that then that today we are and that we
can in fiscal 23
and achieve some of the goals that
departments and the state have
am i correct and assuming and i think i
heard it but i want to nail the point
down it is much
easier and i think cost effective
to help a person who's in danger of
becoming homeless
than it is to
gather up the homeless and get them back
into something
i think it's partly dependent on the
services that are provided around that
person
a person who's in their home doesn't
have to face
that that terrible situation of i don't
know where i'm sleeping
but for those who are in the shelters
the kind of supports that they provide
can provide if they're adequately funded
like job training like
job location
those are terrific services that
hopefully
lift people out i remember andy
sanborn's line we're giving people a
hand up not a handout
senator carson thank you mr chairman may
i ask the question of senator please do
thank you senator um in reading this
i'm sorry
in reading this amendment senator i i
see where the point um is or at risk of
homelessness and i think this speaks to
the question
that has been posed about
helping people before they get homeless
so the allocations of this fund could be
used to address that situation to get to
people before their they find themselves
without a place to live am i correct i
agree with you thank you
senator birdsall
thank you mr chair um with that question
dovetailing on senator carson
um i don't have you heard of the
organization called family promises
would that be
you might be able to answer would that
be an organization that would benefit um
from this potentially so the control
of these funds are with the cities and
towns so it would be up to the cities
and towns um and so they would have that
option but uh um so
it could
so does that help follow follow up
so when we have one hopefully being
built in dairy
will know a little bit later in the
summer
so it would be dairy that would
provide them any funds that they could
correct thank you
or they could use it
in other ways that meet the needs here
senator khan yeah thank you mr chairman
uh senator thanks for that question uh
i i checked in on hampstead uh to see
what kinds of uh
indirect as well as direct assistance
the town was providing uh currently they
are providing uh indirect assistance to
homeless uh people through isaiah 58
right through a community services uh
organization
uh and through the rockingham county
services
uh
and
yeah so they uh
they they demonstrated
around a thirty million thirty thousand
dollar uh
expense out of the town's budget to
support homelessness uh but not in a
direct subsidy
all politics is local representative
edwards
so um i i buy into the theory that
um helping somebody at risk before they
become homeless is preferable than
waiting until they are homeless and have
a much bigger problem i buy into that
entirely so but it does make me curious
about where the rubber meets the road
when we start to tell these towns that
they can help people at risk who are not
homeless to help pay their mortgages
in order to make sure that that's done
in a
fair way
that's not biased towards their best
friend of 20 years
do we have guidance written today
that would explain
how to apply some fair process to
determining who is at risk and how at
risk they would be because if you're at
risk you could be like
crucially seriously like tomorrow at
risk or you could be
three months i may have a problem so so
i i it just feels very hard to write
guidance around that what what what have
you been able to do so there's like
there's a couple of things because i
think each city and town has their own
guidelines for how they provide welfare
assistance and they have a welfare
officer and so that would come into play
at the same time we're doing a lot of
work with certain welfare directors in
certain communities and providing
support and guidance like we had one
community that was re that reached out
to the department to say you know we're
seeing an increased number of people
needing assistance and so we actually
partnered the department and a welfare
director from a larger city met with
that town and really helped give them
some guidance and some ideas on how to
follow so we would still have to follow
whatever rules your city or town may
have but i think by
really working
with the welfare directors around
helping people stay in their homes i
think that that is a little different in
some communities than others
did i answer your question
follow-up representative edwards so it
sounds to me like what you just said is
that this is new state money that's
going to the towns and that to the
extent that they happen to have rules
similar about helping at-risk people
they could certainly use their own
guidelines but at the state level we
have not yet developed any guidelines on
how to define at-risk and
what kind of proportionality that that
may justify in using state funds so we
could
um
we would be developing guidelines for
states for communities to follow
but unless there's something added in
here we don't have a lot of authority
to say oh you used it inappropriately
but we could put very strict guidelines
as to how you use it but yet we want to
be careful that there's flexibility
that that's the piece in senator khan
representative turcotte
thank you mr chairman
i want to
go a little bit further than
represent edwards what he said about
at-risk i would
agree
that it's a
very vague term
and for me it's would be open to a lot
of interpretation and that may be good
or bad
the chairman of the committee mentioned
the budget process i do believe also
that's the place for this
the last part
in reading at least this
amendment that was distributed
when it talks about
re-housing shelter
and then it talks about landlords um
having been one myself in a distant past
i know there already exists multiple
layers of
programs to help those who are in
looking at eviction or
whatever
and i can say the majority tenants that
we had in the past were excellent
tenants but i can also
say that
there might have been some that i
might not want the town
necessarily helping and remain in one of
our units
so
i think as a whole i i would prefer to
see this in the budget process myself
um
i have problems with the
the terms at risk and
there i think there's some potential
landlord issues there also thank you mr
chairman
thank you representative the chair calls
on representative hunt
i just did want to say we could um use
the hud guidelines um
that are that outline for people
experiencing homelessness so we would
put that in any guidance thank you
representative hunt yeah so um
not that this is my issue at all
but i have been on
uh commute of conference before
and uh and actually
got got into trouble once
when
we had a
amendment that came in
and the amendment was not in either the
house or senate version
that it was a new language completely
and i assume
is at risk is a new conversation item
and that
i was
my
amendment they we was found at the by
the speaker at the time
that it was not permissible
because it was not in either the house
or senate version it's a new material so
whenever you introduce new material um
it it jeopardizes the committee
conference so so my understanding is we
cannot
take up this amendment at all
because it's new new a new subject
or new interpretation with this at-risk
concept senator khan thank you mr
chairman
so if we want to go back to the words
that are in here it's homeless people
seeking shelter
uh
and i'm fine with doing so i i think
uh what
the department is uh looking to do and i
think what
assists the local government
is to recognize that
there is a
opportunity
to
help people avoid the homeless situation
can is there
i mean we're talking about safety net
issues here right
uh
people
fall into homelessness i mean
they fell they've fallen through a
safety net and we need to rebuild it
um
the safety net
uh if it if it can be in place to help
people from falling
uh then that's terrific
right there's some legitimacy to the
question
raised about a local community
will they how will they exercise that
decision about at-risk
but i think that what the department is
doing here with this last line that
they're going to use their relationship
with local welfare administrators
association a body which actually does
exist and is entirely populated by
uh
community
welfare
officers
that that they will develop these best
practices for use and i guess i come
back to one
we did consider this in the budget
process we assumed we we
legislated that there were not the
dollars until we came to this point
and there are
many items that we're going to face as
we come out of this legislative session
adding dollars to
that we weren't unable to do in our
original budget allocation for this
biennium this is not an isolated
instance
uh number one number two um
we're trying
something different here
if
by allocating only to shelters
to answer the issue of homelessness or
at risk of homeless
doesn't reach enough
people in our state doesn't reach enough
communities is not providing local
relief to local governments in a
sufficient way
then this is the way to do it
distributing dollars on a fair basis
across every community allows every
community that determination as to how
to best use these dollars so
i i i'm coming back around to you know
the main point here and
i hope that
we can get to the place of supporting
this amendment thank you a few questions
for me number one is there anything to
prevent
the towns
generating the dollar amounts that are
listed if they saw that there was a
homeless problem in their town and they
wanted to deal with their town people
i
i don't think there is anything
preventing i think what we
are anticipating what we can see in
front of us right now there is a bubble
and can we provide enough housing
where that can be relieved and right now
we are facing
housing people in in hotels
and in shelters that
need additional space and and some
renovation these are the way this is a
mechanism to get the dollars to the
towns for them to
either directly provide the assistance
or to participate along with other towns
to get that assistance provided which
begs my question about whether if the
money is not given to the towns the
towns cannot put it in their budget or
out of their reserve or rainy day fund
and i believe my answer would be of
course they can
my second question is um
i don't remember was there a hearing on
this bill
in the house did it go to a policy
committee
i know that it went to the finance
committee and i guess i'm
going to need some
help there
because representative pearson likely
has a recall of this
not really
well the the underlying bill started off
as a senate bill eventually was tabled
and then
re-inserted into the bill in front of
you uh hb 1662 at the most recent uh
senate session so to my knowledge at
least the underlying bill that was filed
uh uh as prime sponsor by senator khan
did not um have a hearing here in the
house
okay
but if there's another bill i
i don't have knowledge of that i think
the way that i was
anticipating some response is that in
when the department uh proposed
additional funding for
uh homelessness
how was that filed
in 2020
okay
instead of truth yeah as part of our
budget request yes okay that's how it
was filed
senator carson
thank you mr chair um i have
a couple of questions um and i want to
understand what the dialogue here is
going on
because you had asked about local
resources to address the issue of
homelessness
versus getting a grant from the state
for homelessness
are you suggesting that
municipalities
raise local property taxes in order to
get the money to fund a homeless problem
they have in their community
versus getting a state grant
no
okay could you clarify
that please because very often certain
line items go down and certain light
items go up depending on a whole variety
of things
and to say
the money that would have come from the
state needs to be generated locally does
not require in itself property taxes to
go up
because some other things may go down
i'm just simply saying can the towns not
assume more of the local welfare needs
that's all i'm asking okay thank you um
i live in hampstead and pay property
taxes which are way too high i think we
all do so
thank you for your answer the second
question that i have and it's it's
suggestion concerning about the
procedure
um in the senate this bill was brought
forward during a senate session
we had a great debate and a discussion
about this particular issue and it was
voted on by the full senate i believe it
passed 24 to nothing but i think if the
house has questions about
the procedure what i'd like to suggest
mr chair is that we take a break
and that you consult with the house
clerk
to make sure that you are following your
procedures
and i don't
i'm asking my researcher if she would
find out if this bill did come over to
us
representative enforcing what you're
just saying is
that they'll rule
this is a non-tremaine amendment
ingenious in a sense to the committee of
conference because
neither
house or senate version
had this language
so we i'm arguing
yeah i'm arguing that we could never
take up this amendment because it wasn't
even in your version
they're saying if it was in your version
if you had amended this
when you amended this you know this bill
and added the this whole section in the
bill if you had added this at that time
it would be drained because you guys
have rules that allow you anything but
this is all new language here right this
it's been in particular i'm just
thinking i was you know sitting here and
there's at risk there's a whole new
concept
so that is i'm arguing that that our
clerk would rule that this is not this
cannot be permitted in the committee
conference report when my researcher
comes back with the answer to the first
question i'll ask her to go ask that
question correct senator
yes
for a moment we do have the wording that
is on page four of
the senate approved bill
otherwise you would withdraw this and
just stick to where we're
yes if it's not timely to introduce it i
just thought that it maybe added some
clarification to
uh okay
at least that the department wanted to
have here while we're waiting for the
clerk to come over um representative
turcotte did you wish to jump in at this
point on this point
yes mr chairman
um so it's my understanding i want to
make sure i get this right
this although this amendment to 1662
starting on page
bottom of five on the bottom of five
and continuing on with all the dollar
distribution levels
this passed the house but never was
voted on
uh past the senate but was never
voted on by the house is that correct
never heard i don't recall this thank
you and the clerk of the house will be
over very shortly to
say more
representative edwards uh and since we
have some dead air here while we're
waiting i i
as i'm listening to this i'm thinking
what a fascinating policy discussion
this is and that if only we had a
committee in the house that was good at
reviewing this sort of policy
maybe they could have looked at it and
provided a recommendation to the finance
committee to whether we could consider
funding it or not and
and then i would i would also want to
just add that we are months weeks away
from starting another budget phase and
that maybe
maybe this could be brought into the
right process
you do know the speaker said he would
afflict bodily harm on me if i approved
yet the establishment of another
commission or committee
i'm not asking for that oh good i'm
asking for let's
we've got a budget
okay
well that was the second half of yeah
you were talking about it
i think you'll probably come in about
two seconds into doing that
representative so if i may i i i just
you know i i worked with senator khan
for a long time i have tremendous
respect for him this sounds like a
really great program i like saving
people at risk before they go over the
cliff
but i i just think this is a major
policy issue for which the house
has never
visited it
and that it would be appropriate for the
hhs committee to set this kind of policy
um and and not have it done in a
committee a conference i
all right so so that's i'm i'm a leaning
now all right uh clerk of the house
would you come forward please because we
are asking for a few rulings on things
mr chairman yes
i'm wondering if we could hold for a few
minutes because i have called the senate
clerk and she is on her way over as well
well the senate clerk can come too
and i don't think they'll be speaking at
once but
no and i'd like to bring up the point
that it's my understanding in a
committee a conference this morning an
amendment was adopted and approved by
both sides so um i think we just need to
get some clarification on this
particular issue it's my understanding
that
this has been done many many many times
in the past but since the issue has been
brought up i think we need a ruling from
both sides thank you i agree with you
and i see we have two very different but
parallel issues here one should we do
this
and secondly may we do this and they're
separate issues
if we may do this we don't necessarily
want to do this we could
but
if it is ruled out of order
by certainly since i represent the
house's side i'm introduced interested
in hearing what the clerk of the house
has to say and if it's not kosher to him
then it won't be kosher to me even
though your clerk may make it kosher for
you
and then once that dust is settled it's
do we want to do this or say no wait to
the next budget
totally get it
the clerk of the house rules that we may
do this
so the question then becomes do we wish
to
and i think we've discussed that
very thoroughly
and i would ask the senate
do you wish to i think it would be
obvious do you wish to defend the
senate's position
in this
okay
i would presume you would but i would
want to hear it
senator carson we're we're moving on to
vote uh on the issue of
this second part of the bill and the
question is do you with your senate
colleagues wish to defend the um
senate's position on this yes
all right now the house
yeah the the house representative
turcotte yay or nay
nay
representative hunt um i clearly this
needs to go to a committee before we
could vote on so i would say nay
okay but that kills it then a great
potential policy
worthy of hhs
and i would say the same kind of thing
much needed wrong way to do it so
the house position is no so therefore
section two
will is has been voted out mr chairman
i'm going to request
that the
senate take
a a break
so we can uh discuss the rest of the
bill
so okay how long do you need
um
maybe a half an hour
okay
so i've been invited to the israeli
general consulate meeting okay so it
starts at two
and two
it's time
you wanted to caucus on items three and
four relevant to what we just did to
items one and two
uh
mr chairman we just wanted to discuss
the bill in total so i appreciate that
yep
yeah we were having an intellectual
stimulating conversation too oh we were
talking about the red sox
and the season the upcoming season
i can name you the 1961 starting lineup
that would be interesting we'll do that
yes
i used to know the starting lineup of
the 1967 baltimore orioles
we talked about
the hockey bruins losing
but the celtics winning but the celtics
won there's one bright spot
so now it's
depending on the red sox to have a great
season
and bring us
bring us up
bring us a championship i'm holding my
breath
we are too it'll be a great hopefully
the weather will be great
a lot of good times down in boston at
the red sox stadium and should we all
stand and sing one versus sweet caroline
no you don't want to hear me sing okay
item number three amends the provisions
relating
to payment of an employee's wage by
direct deposit
and this is a senate um
i don't want to use a bad term i'm going
to say add-on but i don't mean that
pejoratively
attached to this bill so could we hear
from the senate about uh
why we should consider it positively
thank you mr chairman um and i
appreciate
your
um
you're
letting me speak about this bill um
this bill i think is something that we
really need to do we are far far far
behind the times when it comes to
electronic payment of wages and so this
bill really permits employers to pay
those wages electronically
we already allow people to have
especially if you get
any kind of federal subsidy
money is goes from one to the other
right into a direct deposit that the um
that the recipient
[Music]
designates and so this mr chairman just
goes along those lines there's a couple
of sta
points i'd like to make most states in
the united states already allow
um this to go on and if any of you have
seen
uh the chime commercials out there
where they advertise you know a company
that you can get the money
a day or two prior to actually
receiving a paper check it's
automatically put into your account and
it's available for people to use
again 29 states permit electronic page
layman's there's no complaints
employees tend to quickly adapt and are
awful and often very thankful for the
ability to have this
they would like to be able to choose
between direct
deposit or payroll cards at any time
and employers
prefer this because now
you they're really not dependent upon
anyone receiving a paper check it's not
saying that an employee cannot request a
paper check they can but
most employees would prefer to receive
some sort of an electronic card
again the point most payments are
already electronic virtually all
government payments are paid
electronically
tax refunds unemployment social security
nutrition assistance disability
etc 93 of american workers are already
paid via direct deposit
um
just a little factoid mo european
workers have not seen a paper paycheck
in decades
government employees are generally all
paid electronically and it's only really
the private sector employees
remain mired in wage payment laws better
suited to the 1940s
so in talking about payroll cards
they can use them any place that they
would use a check
there's free online bill payment in
internet shopping there's no charges for
those
travel oftentimes requires electronic
payment for flights
hotels rental cars etc there are
protections from fraud and unauthorized
use and a dispute resolution process in
place they can't be overdrafted
so there's no fees
and they often include free savings
account and additional cards for family
members
this bill passed
the senate
and
it went over to the house and the house
heard it and
they made the motion of interim study
so the senate feels very strongly about
this bill it's time that we
join the modern age
and hopefully we can
talk about this and see if we can get
this passed thank you mr chair yes
question to the senator most of my
employees
already have direct deposit of their
paycheck into their bank account so what
i'm hearing that
we need this for some very special
reason and my people already get this
what am i missing thank you for the
question mr chair it really gives the
employee
choice about how they want to receive
their paycheck um some people don't want
to deal with a bank
they don't want to deal with um paying
fees everything else to a bank
um some people just don't want to have
credit cards either
um so they would like to get something
like this where the money is
automatically taken out um everything is
online where they can go at any point
and look to see what their balances are
it's just another an alternative way to
pay people my employees have this now
they
they would have direct deposit but they
would have the option of having a pay
card
what is a pay card is i know what a
check is i know what direct deposit is
what is a paid card a pay card is just
like a card that you would get
for like your debit card
and your paycheck is loaded onto that
card instead of sending it to the bank
it's loaded onto the card
like a donkey donuts card
where you buy it and then every time you
go i this i'm only hearing about this i
don't do this but you go through the
drive through and you hand them the card
and it debits down what you just your
triple mocha latte aposino thing that
you just bought and now your card
shrinks in value is it like that okay so
it's like a donkey kong that's right but
uh wow well you could buy a lot of
dunkin donuts with your paycheck but
um no i could if that's if that's your
thing if you like yeah you know donuts
that
it's the money is always readily
accessible to you you're saying the
third option this brings in is a pay
card like that okay thank you i got it
now okay senator birdsall um i would
think of it um and every week it's the
um your paycheck is loaded back on much
like an ebt card works
the government every week
puts your
money loaded loads it up on your ebd
card
and then
you use your ebt card it's much like
that
i'm a dinosaur
representative turcotte
thank you mr chairman
um
this bill did come over from the senate
um to our labor committee
on which i sit
um we over a couple weeks in several
public hearings
we
looked at this
particular
uh wording we looked at multiple
amendments from individuals on our
committee um
at the very end we actually i put in a
an amendment that brought it back to the
senate's original uh version
that final amendment attempt i should
say failed
that was followed by the motion for
interim study
i can tell you that this issue has been
in our committee now on and off for a
very long time
i can tell you um
that section of employment law
is what i would consider
excessive
right now it sits at 695 words on just
how an employer
will pay their
employee not
when or on how many frequent occasions
that used to be
uh every week
unless you got
special dispensation from the the
commission
i actually put in a an amendment on that
to change it to every two weeks because
so many of our employee
businesses wanted a a different time
so that changed
what i'm going to suggest here is that
like so many things we do
we take
what
some would consider horrible language
and continue to make it worse and more
burdensome
on our businesses in the labor committee
our goal is to reduce regulations reduce
burdens
and make everything simplif
simplify everything for our businesses
i'm going to give you a couple examples
of why this is actually
worse than what we already have
but
at the end of our last hearing almost
half jokingly
i said you know what what we need in in
this section instead of 695 words we
need a sentence that says this
upon initial employment the employer
shall inform the employee the method
method of payment for wages earned by
the
employee what a concept simplify
eliminate
three or four paragraphs now i granted
we there need to be a few other little
minor changes in there but this
is just uh
too excessive it makes it more difficult
to understand and like i say we went
through this on our committee for two
weeks going back and forth
we spent an inordinate amount of time on
this and in the end we sent it to
interim study because we believe that's
where it should go
i mean a couple of the the issues that
some of us saw especially
on the very first page of
fort page 14 there in the middle
it talks about uh an employer shall be
liable for late payment of wages really
uh and this this was my favorite
should an employee's payroll card be
lost stolen or damaged let's stick with
loss and the funds are no it's no longer
accessible to the employee
the employer shall be required to
provide the employee with a replacement
card within 24 hours all right so on
friday night i'm out at
my favorite pub and then i happen to
lose my payroll card
i call up saturday morning to my
business
who's closed and say hey i need a
replacement card in 24 hours
so
what i'm going to suggest is we again
labor committee after much much work
said interim study
i'm going to suggest we stick with that
and what i will
offer to the senate
is this fall
if i am reminded of it
i will put in
a bill that actually does
attempt to
bring 695 words down to maybe 50.
because that's where we should be going
we should make it be making it easier
for our businesses
not increasing
the burden on our businesses thank you
mr chairman
anything
um i don't know i think i remember the
seed about the local bank
that that made it came across our
committee but uh evidently uh this
debate of paychecks has been an ongoing
struggle for years and years and years
and
i'm not sure what the right answer is
and i i always seems much more
complicated but i the idea of an
employer having to replace something a
card
in a 24-hour period so if the pay if the
card is lost on a saturday how's the
employer supposed to get that card
to them and
i don't know that seems problematic to
me two sentences above that seem worse
should an employee be unable to access
their wages due to a technical or
processing defect the employer shall
immediately
provide the wages to the employee with a
replacement payroll card etc right
how do you how does how do you how do
you make that happen i mean it should be
quickly but immediately
yes just one more point i forgot to
mention and
this isn't the first place i've seen
this uh there's another
bill or committee conference coming up
tomorrow i believe where it's a similar
situation and we see it a lot in labor
we attempt to fix
a
problem that
only affects a minute portion of our
population we put in 695 words i'm just
using this as an example to fix the one
or one half of one percent of
individuals
who
um
for some reason or another so and when
we do that
you create all these burdens and
expenses on businesses for that one
individual like i say i i really truly
believe for everybody's benefit that the
business should have the ability when
they hire an employee to say
this is how i'm going to pay you we
could even eliminate another 400 words
and say and this is you're going to be
your pay period
would you say then that
let's say i'm looking for work even
though i have three full-time jobs now
but let's say i wanted another one
and i went over to abc widgets which you
won't and you said welcome so glad
you're considering coming to work here
this is how we pay you
you get a payroll check every other week
and i say i don't want that
and you say there's a lot of other
people that are hiring out there and i
go find working for xyz widgets that's
willing to do something differently the
employee the employer has the right
to broaden it or narrow it depending on
the employer's choices and i have the
right to accept or reject accordingly is
that what you're saying
in a shorter version of that yes mr
chairman
but that's exactly the point and again
this is something we emphasize on the
labor committee all the time
the decision on
things that go on within a business
should be between the employer
and the employee or the business and the
employee it shouldn't be
politicians or bureaucrats saying you
have to do this you have to do this you
have to do this
simplify it help our businesses
operate
so in your scenario that's exactly what
i'm suggesting thank you
well since i see nothing further let's
do a vote by orders to see whether we
keep this or not senate
mr chairman we're not voting
individually on each particular session
section we will take one vote on the
bill at the end of
every discussion at the end of the
discussion that is how we do it that is
how who does it that is how we do that's
how your senate the senate wishes to do
this yes we will take one vote on the
bill as a whole
after every after okay that's not how
i've been rolling
thus far but since you've given an
ultimatum i have no choice
representative hunt
um i i think they should take this on
with him
okay and
representative
i think we should take this out we are
voting our way and that is on each item
and you're saying
yes or no to this i'm saying this should
be out i think i've made uh very good
arguments as to a much better option and
okay thank you
sorry that is what the house has done
senate will
respond accordingly item number four
requires third-party sellers to provide
certain information to online
marketplaces and to consumers
and deems the failure to do so a
violation of the consumer protection act
we had a spirited decision while the
senate was caucusing about this and i'm
quite in favor of it
um but
we could cut to the chase because we've
all heard the arguments and i would like
to pull my delegation to see what you're
going to say
and uh this is on item number four
representative edwards third-party
seller's information
and i think we've discussed it to death
uh representative hunt how would you
vote i would like to remove from the
bill and representative turcotte removed
please okay well that's it then because
we have more than one
so now we are done and now we can vote
on the entire bill when we looked at it
individually we said yes
to representative edwards hard work on
secured data in dhhs we all said yes on
that items 2 3 and 4 were said to be out
with the senate voting for and the house
voting
no so
now senate up or down on the whole bill
mr chairman the senate is requesting a
recess to a later date so that we can uh
caucus and look at everything thank you
and the um
recess date will has been scheduled for
10 o'clock tomorrow morning
i can't make that
um i would like to have that
in hand because i'm
having a procedure done on wednesday
and if you could look at your schedules
now and let me know um is there a time
tomorrow other than 4 p.m
they already have something at 4pm
what's that i said we already have
something at 4pm that's why we can't do
this at 4pm
3 30.
and i have committee conferences i i
possibly could do three o'clock tomorrow
afternoon three o'clock would be okay
three o'clock
yeah like that depends on how long
um
some of these other things
and if we can't miss sharon if everyone
can't be here we can always reschedule
it after that
we have until mid-afternoon on thursday
yes
um
so we are
i will be alerting the clerk of the
house for three o'clock tomorrow
afternoon
to come out of recess
thank you
really ambassador since high by the way
oh thanks
he's the general counsel foreign
now
nice
you